alors nous les hommes on pense bien se
connaître et surtout bien connaître sa
verge parce que depuis quand les tout
petits ont fait pipi plusieurs fois par
jour on se masturbe au cou on en parle
beaucoup mais ce qu'on se connaît
vraiment on a tendance à réduire la
sexualité à l'érection on a tendance à
réduire la sexualité à l'éjaculation
il ya plein de choses à connaître ya
plein de choses à apprendre je pense que
ça vous est déjà arrivé à tout le monde
mais je pense que ça vous est arrivé
aussi on a peur de se dé saper dans un
vestiaire on a fait du sport avec ses
copains et à ce moment arrive la douche
et la blocage on the block pourquoi
parce que il ya deux types de verges bon
ce modèle il ya le pénis de son aile
pénis de cherves
il ya des verges qui sont plus ou moins
élastique et qui vont se gorger de façon
spectaculaire en sang je suis comme un
pénis de 200 donc cédé verges qui sont
plutôt modestes au repos mais qui
peuvent doubler voire faire deux fois et
demi leur taille en longueur et en
circonférence le pénis de chair sydney
hq plutôt même longueur au repos et en
érection en fait ce qui va changer c'est
la rigidité
[Musique]
un gland c'est pas aussi sensible que la
pulpeuse danois cha mamelon ya moins de
récepteurs dans un gland que sur un
clitoris assez sûrs et ils sont cinq
essentiellement situés autour de la
couronne du gland cours du blanc vous
avez votre gland et vous avez le petit
robert ça s'appelle la couronne ensuite
ils vont y en a aussi pas mal au niveau
du frein donc le frein c'est le petit
morceau de chair qui rentrent le blanc
et le prépuce et ensuite on en a
évidemment sur le faux de la berge
l'appeler récepteur essentiel dans un
gland c'est à la vibration et à la
chaleur
la plupart des fibres nerveuses c'est
simplement des fibres à la douleur
[Musique]
on est tous éjaculateurs prématurée à un
moment donné ou à un autre de sa vie ou
même dans la même journée où durant le
même week end donc pas le stress pour
être considéré comme évacuateur
prématurée il faut avant une pénétration
vaginale qui dure moins d'une minute
donc qui 80% des cas qui entraîne une
souffrance psychologique et qui est une
évacuation qu'on ne peut jamais
contrôler si vous avez passé tous ces
critères il faut pas vous considérez
comme éjaculateurs prématurée c'est
simplement difficultés à maîtriser a
essayé de de contrôler un peu mieux son
excitation
[Musique]
l'orgasme il faut savoir une chose c'est
que ça se passe au niveau du cerveau et
lorsqu'on arrive à un certain seuil
d'excitation dans le cerveau il ya des
petites molécules qu'on appelle des
neurotransmetteurs et lorsqu'elle se
lâche
d'un coup on a une sensation de plaisir
de plénitude
ça s'appelle un orgasme l'éjaculation
c'est autre chose
l'éjaculation ça sert à la reproduction
donc c'est pour ça que au travers des
siècles au travers des religions
monothéistes essentiellement on a
associé orgasme éjaculation reproduction
[Musique]
un homme peut simuler un orgasme en
éjaculant mais n'ayant aucun plaisir
bien sûr que c'est possible si on n'est
pas arrivé à un certain seuil
d'excitation suffisante dans le cerveau
les petits nouveaux transmetteurs ne
sont pas mariés mais au bout d'un moment
l'éjaculation arrive parce qu'il ya eu
simplement une stimulation souvent par
la vibration au niveau de certains
récepteurs au niveau du gland
bandé c'est un phénomène qui ultra
complexe parce que c'est à sochi corps
et esprit donc pour bien bandés il faut
être bien dans sa tête bien dans son
corps et bien évidemment il faut plutôt
être bien avec son compagnon ou sa
compagne
alors pourquoi lorsqu'on des bancs
lorsqu'on met à une capote ou pourquoi
on des bandes lorsqu'on tape à la porte
ou alors à ce moment-là ça implique quoi
dans notre corps en permanence circulent
deux hormones le cortisol et
l'adrénaline qui sont fabriqués en
partie pour le cerveau mais beaucoup
parlé avec petites gens qu'on est au
dessus des reins qu'on appelle les
surrénales et donc quand on a ça qui
circulent dans le sang
ça bloque la réaction on vous agresse et
ben vous ces critiques du cortisol est
donc vous dépendez parce qu'à ce
moment-là fou il passe dans le sang ces
petites hormones et ses petits thormann
c'est l'antidote de l'érection
je pense que les garçons ont beaucoup
beaucoup à apprendre du travail que font
aujourd'hui les féministes aimait les
femmes en général sur la compréhension
de leur corps sur l'acceptation de leur
corps sur le fait de prendre soin de son
corps il est impératif que les hommes
prennent conscience qu'un corps c'est
certes une enveloppe mais c'est aussi un
véhicule d'émotion